[MUSIC PLAYING]
I run a company
called Quirky, and we
create three brand new consumer
products every single week,
and the ideas for those
products come from people
all around the world
that we've never met.
Come to our site, they
share their ideas,
they vote on which
idea is the best,
and the best ideas in the
world get on the retail shelves
with the help of our
company and our community.
We're a design company.
We're a manufacturing and
supply chain business.
We're a community social
network thingamajig.
We run a back-end payment
system to all these inventors
around the world.
And it's a bunch
of startups in one.
It's like six companies in one.
And making sure that we're
growing each one of them
at the same pace is the
most difficult thing
about what we do a
quirky, because oftentimes
over the past five years, we've
gotten really good at designing
things, but the manufacturing
couldn't keep up.
Or we got really
good at the website
and we couldn't
design enough product.
And making sure we're leveling
up each one of these things
correctly at the
same time and not
letting any one get ahead of
itself is a bit of a mess,
but we do it.
We love the chaos, and we don't
take pride in the usual things
that startups take pride in.
Our company does not celebrate
how much money we've raised
or who our investors are or
who we're partnered with.
We take pride in the
inventors we help
and the products we ship,
and everything else is noise.
And that's the principles
that guide the business,
and we just stay
true to who we are,
and we try to be as
authentic as possible.